Yeah.
Keep fighting the good fight. Don't
be afraid of the fence. Actually.
A healthy bit of caution is
good, but a, yeah. Anyway,
check my temperature.
Jama got a fever.
It's spelled BTC. Yeah. I'm a believer.
The revolution started back in
2008 to Toshi. Put Pen to paper,
said it ain't too late. The
future is now, but money exchange.
It's so behind.
Let's make currency and cryptography
align money and cryptography of Judah for
Matt. Send a mill in the
ministry to Kenya and back.
No middle men, no limits, no charge
backs. Make them digital stacks.
No wasting time on green backs.
Who ruptured the zen to me
or power centrally. Cajun us.
We ain't Bree. Oh, so many fearful
leaf network is done by many.
Not just the view. If you want to join
open, no wallet and we'll include you.
That's right. I'm the big
coin. Barron. Just follow me.
I'll take you the big coin habit.
Jeez.
Our rock block chains play
in all them stock gain.
It's a public record with
no central effort. Ah,
open source protocol. A straight
up fact. Minors carry. Yes. Hr Two,
five, six on they backs. They'd be
gender written. 21 million coins.
Make it rain. Big Coin every
day. Free to join banking.
Millions of peeps from China to Brazil.
Every one wants a piece
of Dat digital shill.
They say absolute power
corrupts absolutely. Well,
big coin trucks that
very same power rudely.
I'm looking at you politicians who lie
you'd be running but ain't no where to
hide. It's a network that
proves it's fair. Red.
Just we don't need a God in encryption.
We trust.
I have bitcoin dreams of a world that
is free of fantasy of BTC creativity.
If you were big coin bore year,
stand up.
We the chosen ones who never give up.
We'll throw this piece from the west
to the east federal. Try to stop us.
We can't be policed.
It started with one and now with millions,
but just way,
pretty soon it's Billy
is. Yeah, that's right.
Worldwide recognize you can't stop us.
Decentralized
public ledger, no secrets. Ever.
Think about it.